hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swoosh what a lead podcast
or if this is your first time which i'm
sure today's guest has brought in a few
well then welcome to the podcast i do
really hope you enjoy this episode
because there are plenty of other lads
who have been on in the past who you can
go back and listen to but before we get
into this one we must thank our sponsors
who continue to help bring this podcast
to you without them this would not be
possible firstly our major sponsor swish
we have an unreal platform where you can
get a personalized video message from
one of your favorite sports stars some
of the biggest names in the game are on
there including today's guest and they
make an awesome gift idea so go and get
someone a swish and make their dream
come true stars range from 300 down to
20 dollars and it is super easy to use
and if you use the code water lad you
can get 15 off your order and to make it
even more attractive up to 70 of the
proceeds go to kiwi kids charities i'll
leave a link in the description so go
click on that and go check out all the
stars on there
also the legend that is tim bateman
still has this opportunity for any
waterlab listeners where you can own
your very own o studio o studio is a
modern wellness center
we can just go get away from it all
there's recovery rooms float tanks
saunas they do yoga massage meditation
everything you need to get your body and
mind feeling at its best timmy's o
studio in christchurch is going so well
that is now looking to expand across the
country and potentially the world and
timmy will help guide you through the
process of getting set up and making
this transition into owning your very
own business as smooth as possible if
you're interested in finding out more
i've left a link in the description for
you to inquire and can someone out there
please set one up in nelson and i will
be your first member it is such a cool
space
anyway guys i have an absolute legend on
the show for you guys today so let's get
to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah what a lad now today i'm in the
presence of one of the toughest lads in
the game he's had one hell of a career
which is seen and won super rugby titles
with the chiefs pretty much all the
trophies possible with the all blacks
including the rugby world cup and of
course again just recently he's been
named the all black captain he is
without a doubt one of the most
respected players by his teammates in
the country and he is one hell of a
great lad it is the great man himself
sam kane welcome mate who's jimmy i've
been a long time listener um
and admire your introductions so it's an
honor to be honest thank you
mate i'm stoked everyone i know you're a
busy man you're preparing for a huge few
test matches coming up your recent
father um mate but you still found some
time for what a lab that shows you what
a lad you are yeah we had to reschedule
a couple of times i um
underestimated how i'd be going still
learning and adjusting the life as a as
a father but
loving it man yeah how have you found
that have you found being a dad yeah
it's it's not like anything else like in
terms of
like just one day you know it's coming
because she's pregnant but one day it
just changes like the baby's there it's
not like you can ease into it like most
other things in life and get a bit of a
grip or a handle for it you're like
throwing in the deep end and um it's
just a steep learning curve but we're
really fortunate to have lots of support
around which um
sort of gives you a bit of an insight to
the old saying around like they say
takes a village to raise raise your
child and didn't really yo you don't
really understand you never know until
you've you've had a child yourself and
you're in it
and we're only
coming up seven weeks on it so um still
in the very very early stages but um
yeah it's it's flipped everything on its
head and it but it's amazing too yeah
made it soak away there's it is an
experience that you can't really
comprehend until you're in a day and
like you say it's cool that you've got
um family support around because that's
going to be obviously massive for harry
while you're traveling around and doing
obviously the job that you have to do
yeah i've had a few people say all right
you get march um a tuna leave or time
off
and i said oh um baby was born wednesday
night uh big training day thursday and
cape said oh just don't you can miss gym
in the morning just come and sessions
but yeah it makes you um
i appreciate what the
what the mothers go through especially
the mothers of the rugby boys or other
professions who you have to just
push on yeah 100 but let's start with
the recent news obviously just being
named captain again uh must be an unreal
feeling what's what's that like yeah
obviously amazing um
slightly different to the to the first
time um
first time certainly wasn't expecting it
knew i'd sort of be in the mix um it was
a funny season was that covered year i
think we only had six test matches
uh we lost the argentina there's a lot a
lot of pressure
but learnt heaps from the experience and
what it actually what's actually
involved in being an all blacks captain
so then 2021 was really looking forward
to sort of putting a lot of those things
in place that i've learned and just
having a better understanding of what
the job requires
and then to pick up that shoulder and
dream be up for majority of the year was
the timing was just so frustrating um
so then this time um body's feeling
really good but certainly not taking my
position in the squad or assuming that i
was going to get the captaincy again uh
so yeah when fozzie rang me and asked if
i began to do it
absolutely it's a it's obviously a
massive honor how early does he tell you
that and do you have contact with them
throughout the season uh he told me
so we played friday night against the
crusaders we'd got home um was just
hitting until i just arrived at one of
the boys houses for our sort of uh
in the doo
and then um i'm sorry i was this phone
was ringing i'm not gonna answer with
all the music and the boys around so
i ducked outside and answered and they
asked ask me again so that was only
well that was saturday only a couple
days before the team was named on monday
yeah but during the season um yeah we
chat a wee bit but i know i think he
chats to a few of us respected leaders
and guys that he um trusts to bounce
ideas off and things that he's seeing as
well and
then we have a couple of um leadership
meetings throughout the
through our super rugby and you
mentioned that first year in the camp or
as being a captain what was the what's
the biggest difference for you what's
the hardest thing for you to adjust to
or the biggest thing you learnt well the
biggest thing i learned was how
demanding the role was like in terms of
you can't finish training or finish your
day and then just switch off yeah i
found it really hard to switch off and
probably because i also
doubled down with the fact that we had
it's unusual to have six test matches in
a row
other than a world cup year so have that
in a first time skipper and then under
you know a little bit of performance
pressure because we weren't going as
well as we wanted it just sort of
accumulated and as a result i was
found really hard to switch off and was
always thinking about what could we be
doing better
yeah catching up with different people
coaches at night in the evenings before
bed like just pretty constant and
relentless it probably wasn't until
we got into isolation when we got back
from aussie and i was just so flat and
deflated for about two or three days and
it was just sort of like the
the come down almost of what we've just
gone through and i think when i was in
isolation reflecting on it there wasn't
any point that i thought i don't want to
be doing this or i don't like this it
was we still saw it as like an awesome
challenge and was
learning all the time and then super
determined to do
everything i could and we could to make
sure we're performing the best we could
and you mentioned that pressure
obviously there's a lot of pressure on
you the whole country's behind you
everyone wants the best out of the all
blacks do you feel that pressure on not
only your captaincy but your performance
yeah absolutely um and it's
look as long as i've been in the all
blacks i think probably as long as the
elbows have
been around and there's always been
that public pressure and
i've been extremely lucky to be in a in
some
really outstanding all blacks teams
going through some pretty crazy periods
and international rugby where success
was so high
and
that just grows the demand and the
expectations of the public that it can
continue but at the same time like our
own expectations in camp and as players
is to go out there and win every game
and that's not there's the pressure from
the public there's our own expectation
but there's also this all black legacy
that they've done that for so many years
and you want to make sure do everything
you can we can to make sure that
continues so
um
without a doubt you feel the pressure
and i think probably more so
these days probably because we're all on
social media such a big part of
everyone's lives and try to minimize it
at some point but you just you just
can't hide from it and it gives everyone
so many people at home a voice to to
voice what they think so you mentioned
social media how do you avoid that on
social media obviously the keyboard
warriors are out in full force pretty
much every selection
yeah how do you avoid it how do you not
see it oh at the 2019 world cup i just
made it a conscious if it wasn't going
to open any uh any articles yeah um full
stop that was all right i mean like so i
don't don't avoid it by any means but i
sort of almost like can
try to brush things aside a little bit
more like not tape them
what might not take them so so
personally or so hard and sort of have
that view that oh that's that's that's
their opinion that's fine
sometimes you just gotta laugh and and
um
yeah i think someone's told me once that
if you're gonna um
accept positive praise whether it's on
social media or from the media and
articles and
you allow that to make you feel good
it's a slippery slope because
you're also gonna have the
the contour of that which is the the
negative stuff and when you see that or
read that
you're going to feel [ __ ] about yourself
so the best
one of the better bits of advice i've
had is people's feedback that you really
need to get uh are your teammates your
coaches and your ones and your sort of
your close circle and value theirs
so because as soon as you start putting
adding weights to
comments online or or even articles
about how well you play one week and
then how poor the following week then
it's a pretty vicious cycle yeah yes not
good you're spot on a cause like for the
keyboard warriors you're only one good
performance away from now being like the
the greatest player of all time again
and then one bad performance you're like
what's he doing as captain sort of like
absolutely absolutely yeah
but i know one thing for sure is you are
extremely well respected by your
teammates and the guys who who know you
who have played with you i remember that
poll i think it was last year or the
year before you're voted as the toughest
player to play with 44 toughest player
in the game
i think you're the most respected player
as well so everyone who's played with
you or against you knows how tough and
how good you are
um still got to convince some of these
keyboard warriors that's all right i'll
keep trying
but what's your thoughts on the squad
deface island yeah obviously i feel like
at the moment some of the the depth that
we have in new zealand rugby is crazy
man yeah like some of the positions
these seriously good rugby players who
who are missing out um must been a heck
of a job for the selectors and i think
like as awesome as it is to see some of
the new boys you also feel for some of
the boys that have missed out but you
have to assume like it's a it's a long
year and this is only the first series
that a lot of those guys are only one
injury or one opportunity away but
i think it's a i think it's a good squad
i i really do and just
um excited to come in and
get us all together um i was we had a
little camp last week at the mount with
all the guys that went in
uh the super rugby finals which as it
turned out there was only i think 15 of
us 14 of us
nine chiefs three hurricanes and two
highlanders and then the rest of the
squad was planned so they'll obviously
um do the end of season thing and they
coming on so we're going to camp monday
they come in tuesday so we'll be
together tuesday how good mate it's
exciting times anyone in particular
you're looking to sing on the big stage
any of the new caps um we're cool with
peter gus saw cooler yeah can get her
can get a run obviously look those fords
is one of those positions that's um yes
it's so many good players i think
um philadelphia
has just got a really exciting running
game you know you can put people into
space around the rack um been a been a
fan of his for for a couple of seasons
and was pretty gutted to see him have
last last year interrupted with his aco
injury yeah one of those injuries you
never want to see anyone or yourself
yeah um just having had to tackle lester
a couple of times mate the first time i
was in a pre-season
and i thought i could hit him reasonably
well and he just kept moving yeah i was
like far out this guy's strong so yeah
he's a hard man to stop he just doesn't
give up he keeps fighting yeah looking
forward to seeing him go and those
others you mentioned as well but it is
going to be an awesome series of ireland
coming to new zealand um they're
obviously a really good side um bringing
a few kiwis over with them as well no
doubt j-lo will be looking to chow in
your face and get right in your grill
one of those guys that's like you look
look at him
so then you play
such a good follower it's normally the
case the ones who piss you off on the
field of the bigger blokes yeah
what are you looking forward to the
series obviously last you didn't get to
play in front of the your home crowd so
that's going to be a huge buzz getting
to play in front of the kiwis again yeah
um well there's been a bit of a rivalry
i reckon that's sort of growing between
us and the irish dude
how well they've
gone and how much they've improved on
the world stage um and then the fact
that
they've they've got us twice
over there
and obviously the most recent one just
last year so um
yeah to have them here at home we'll
have our home crowd yeah sold out in
park first test is just epic so
hopefully it's slightly different killer
fish because their crowd over there is
something else
the way that they
sing and and makes it makes so much
noise but then they're silent when goal
kickers are taking a shot at goal
it's awesome i think irish people are
awesome too so hopefully plenty of them
are coming out and it should be a really
cool series i've heard um
fawzi say in his opinion it's the
biggest series since new zealand since
the british and irish lines and probably
have to agree it's gonna be it's gonna
be awesome yeah mate no down pump for it
when do you start finding out whether
you're starting or not is that that sort
of last week obviously you'll be
starting as skipper but uh when do the
rest of the guys no i'd say they won't
find out or
the team's normally named to us tuesday
tuesday just before training yeah um and
then it's announced publicly on thursday
so of the test week yeah
yeah there's the naming and then there's
the actual the 23 play which will
give everyone probably an indication of
what direction things are hitting yeah
mate like it's so hard to try and work
out what the selectors are going to go
there's so many different options and
combinations they could pick to make a
really strong squad so it is going to be
really interesting that first squad
but anyway we will crack on i do um i
could talk to you about all blacks all
day but i do want to get to
get to know you a little bit more one
thing i do always like is hearing how um
some of these regular guys end up
becoming the all black captains so
they're upbringing and stuff so what
will give us a rundown on your
upbringing all right um
oh god
awesome upbringing i love my childhood
i'm from
a small town called ripara which is in
between rotorua and taupo
central north island and um
both my both my parents are from riparoa
also so they went to the local high
school it's a small high school
about 400 kids co-ed um from form one to
seven all year was it seven to thirteen
now yeah and
yesterday they met at high school
childhood sweethearts and then um
they're both from farming backgrounds
and uh dad
yeah brought a farmer in repair and
i'm one of three three children so i'm
the oldest i've got two younger sisters
and uh we grew up on a dair farm which
is a little bit unusual for the district
like predominant reprise pretty much uh
all dairy farmers oh yeah your ma'am
said uh after growing up on a dairy farm
he wasn't didn't want to be milking cows
so um he mentioned them to deer which
has just been awesome and i saw that her
child had grown spending a lot of time
on the farm i was lucky my dad's right
into his footy as well so he was my my
coach
with a couple of um
end up being my best mates dads as well
from the age of five all the way to
fourteen and um
yeah spent lots of
lots of time um on the farm down at the
rugby club just doing sort of
normal a lot of like a lot of sort of
rural kiwi lads mates so many of the
greats um start their life on a farm
what is it about farm life that turns
out so many awesome
yeah i don't know um i've been asked
this question a couple of times like the
only thing
i think when you're on a on a farm and
part of a family on a farm like you
probably learn a little bit we'll have
to have a bit more responsibility at a
younger age whether that's caring for
animals whether that was having to get
up and help
your parents feed out on a saturday
morning so that we could go into our
sport late morning but it's nice i'm not
really sure and then seeing seeing your
parents works maybe long hours um and
and not have weekends off but then
you know farming you have different
parts of the year off depending on on
the season but yeah i sort of always
massively admired my my parents work
ethic um and how hard they've worked for
us and i've got no doubt that's sort of
rubbed off all of us kids as well and
then how did you get into rugby and when
did when did the whole rugby dream start
yeah so i got into rugby as a
five-year-old
got taken down to local rugby club as i
said dad was my coach and um i don't
remember when or how i fell in love with
it exactly but there's no doubt i fell
in love with rugby massively
was that could it
read all the ranking magazines read any
rugby rugby book he could find you
couldn't get me to read anything else
audrey wrote me a book
um
you know watch games look at stats you
know just all that sort of stuff and
yeah i don't know just loved it and um
yeah still do were you good
um
i wasn't the best kid and then now um
you know rugby team growing up there's
always there's but i think that's the
case for a lot of people there's always
like a couple of kids at a young age
you're like wow they are just
outstanding um
we i was really fortunate that bina even
though we're in a small district we had
a from the age of five or six like just
a real good group of of kids my age
i actually ended up playing a year up
above my age um just because all of my
mates were so and i didn't even know
that for the first like four or five
years that i was playing a year above
but i am born in um early january so
it's only just cut off date so yeah
because first of june is that kind of
day but yeah i think
probably the first time i realized that
i was going pretty well at rugby was
when i dropped back down a grade to play
by plenty under 14s so i played for the
bar in the under 14s the previous year
and then all my sort of age group moved
on to try and make their 16s but i could
stay back and that was a year that
i started sort of
playing pretty like
going a lot better yeah sort of having a
bigger impact on games
and i thought oh
man i'm actually playing with my own age
group now and going really well yeah so
that's probably the first first point
but i did miss out on my my first couple
of rep teams as a
sort of 11 12 12 year old which um stung
a wee bit uh my old man must have seen
something of me though because as i was
you know almost in tears in the car on
the way home he's told me to divide my
time i'll get an opportunity one one day
um i don't even know what by my time
but he reminded me of it um years later
what he said
oh look at you now but when you drop
down that grade was that when you were
starting to be labeled the next um
richie mccool because that's the one
thing i remember i remember you being
labelled the next regime accord from
about the age of ten um
if it was like that that never got to me
i never really heard it or took it i
don't think i've ever really heard
um
and then as you get older you hear
coaches i always knew i always knew yeah
it's easy to say now
um
not not that by any stretch on the the
mix for chemical for sure but um
yeah and then i suppose the the next
step was by playing the under 16s the
next year and we're like i said we had a
good a real good group of kids at
redbarra but also and they are plenty at
that time so i was fortunate like just
the timing of my run almost
um and we
we won the national comp up from the
north island or from central north up
and they had a
new zealand under 17s then oh yeah
which we didn't play any games
it was just a squad that got assembled
purely for development purposes um and i
got selected in that
and
again i was a year young for that so i
was only under 15 is technically
obviously good for the zoology 17s and
there was only
there's only a couple of us who were in
that age bracket tj umaro was there
because he was
only a few days apart i can't remember
who else there's heaps of heaps of boys
there but me and him there's only a
couple of us that were a year young
and that's sort of when
penny dropped that almost on the right
track but i had been i'd been training
from a reasonably young age to to get
better at rugby and to try and make it i
suppose what sort of training were you
doing um
mainly just running yeah only running um
but then
i saved up some money and marked down
and brought some weights off trade me
nice terrible weight slot those ones
that are just covered in plastic and
and i had no idea what i was doing i
just um
tried to push or pull something until i
was until i was tired
yeah running we had a rower at home so
sometimes i'd like row for 20 minutes
and jump off and run 20 minutes down the
road just
freestyling but
i suppose the whole time like learning
to push push yourself and learning to
train and enjoy it yeah and this was to
all become a professional rugby player
was that the was that the goal i think
so um
i can't remember what what helped us uh
when i first started running i made him
mine's dead set off and i've been
running for about a month now just down
the farm
and after i get my footy my mate's dad
said oh sam you're playing really well
lately you know you're just everywhere
and that's when i was like oh that makes
a bit of sense i think i'm i think i'm
playing better because i'm with the
extra work i've been doing and that
probably
there's a bit of a light bulb moment and
ever since then
i continually did training outside of
the tuesday thursday but probably one of
my
favorite memories of what really
training but it was learning hard work
was um there was a me and three mates we
had a little
hay picking up game
and we would pick up we'd pick up hay
for uh one of the local farmers yeah
and um
yeah we just felt like
real men you know like we'd be picking
up hay and it was loose soon so we'd
have to pick it up at night so that the
leaf
had enough moisture it wouldn't fall off
and we'd be doing big night shifts and
then turn up to school late the next day
because we're top five from work
or it'd be like weekends or summer days
we would be stacking a hay barn
pop back to one of my mates houses for a
quick feed
um
smack a couple of beers back and then go
back to
stack hey
or all armor and we do like some big
shifts but we're also
um for making some good money and
working hard there's just some awesome
awesome memories there and and like all
those sort of things i think install
hard work and learning to push yourself
a little bit but we also like look back
on it now as my group of mates we always
had a footy a rugby wall on our hands
like take it on the bus to school take
it home
so we're always playing touch before
school
um interval lunch time so technically
that's all a type of training is a skill
development everything but i just loved
it so when you left school um your rice
was pretty rapid you went from bar
plenty pretty young age chiefs young age
and then all blacks young as well it all
happened pretty fast for you so what was
that like yeah well i did most of my
schooling at all of my schooling at rip
road college and then my last year
school uh went to tauranga boys
and that was that that year sort of got
more of a taste of
serious training like having actual
trainers we were part of the bad clinic
academy it was me and a me and a mate
from ripper
um because total boys don't have a
hostel
so we had to move oh we moved over but
we're boarding with a lady vicky simple
and and her house was awesome and was
have to learn as 17 year olds to
um six o'clock trainings in the morning
go to school and then train in the other
was like quite a steep learning curve
and uh
not without its hookups
gotten a little bit of trouble
the first game of
the first game for today boys was
against hamilton boys it was a
pre-season and it was a curtain razor
for the chiefs
and
me and my mate carl we were we were
named on the bench and old man rings up
goes oh how come whom you guys are on
the bench we had to tell him uh that
when we missed missed the training
because what do you mean
i said well
we had with training in the morning for
the academy we were so tired we went
back to bed
so i missed school
and um it was before there was like
whatsapp groups or anything like that
and
the first thing coaches sent like a note
around to each of the schools for the
teachers to read out you know the first
15 boys there's a line out session at
lunchtime yeah in the gym
because we were in at school we didn't
get it so we missed the line out session
i mean if we'd known we would have
happily driven into school for the one
hour training
but we weren't so the coach
dropped us to the bench and me and my
mate carl we were supposed to be sort of
these um
good
good additions to the tauranga
yeah so dad
he's not someone who like raises his
voice or gets too angry but he'll let
you know he's disappointed but that day
he said don't you ever miss another
effing day of school
or i'll pull you out of school myself
and don't think you're coming back to
ripper
you can go and get a job
you know you can kiss goodbye to new
zealand second excuse he knew that that
was a goal of mine oh yeah
yeah so that was um made me go to school
for the rest of the year and then um
and then from there um he had played
club footy the next season
they booed for
bayer plenty i can't even remember what
it was called then in pc um
it was lucky to get picked up for the
wider training group gig with the chiefs
which was only part time back then yeah
as you you'll probably remember yeah uh
and you could only play if there was i
think two injuries in your position
yeah and
yeah later on in the season there was
two injuries like i mean scott waldron
and tonight latimer both got injured so
i was lucky my first
game for the chase
went over with the boys to johannesburg
and and debuted off the bench um reverse
the lions yeah only only got about five
or six minutes but ran around like a mad
dog first
first taste of altitude yeah and yeah
obviously just
just burning we're defending for the
game too i remember clay craig clark
stanley saying who have you got
on defense i could hardly speak because
i just gone too hard too quickly
um so luckily we won likely one and then
[Music]
yeah what was that so i was 19.
thank you for the chase at 19.
um
next year got a full another year of
provincial rugby had uh
started
now me and me and tonight were sharing
sort of starting duties for the chiefs
in 2012 yeah and then um
yeah maybe all blacks there same year
hugely unexpected though back then they
had
the coaches would go around
um
and and talk to players and get almost
we're almost you're almost interviewed
and yet to present what you're working
on
what was going well and
wayne smith was with the chiefs at the
time and he was like mate it's just
these are serious interviews so you'd
help prepare all of our boys that the
coaches wanted to talk to but i wasn't
one of the players that the coaches
wanted to talk to they had a list of
about eight guys
and um
i wasn't disappointed in that point you
mean you know i was 20 years old
sharing starting duties
but not by any means expecting or hoping
to make mill blacks that yeah so i had a
bit of a time frame in my head that if i
get there by 23 or 24
but then
then i got a text that night from dave
rennie saying the coaches have mucked up
and they do want to see you tomorrow
morning so then i was pretty rattled
because
i wasn't prepared like
so i was excited
and but rattled
yeah so then went in and had a like a
little bit of a interview or so yourself
i supposed to
to steve hansen and
and then he said oh we're gonna we're
gonna name a training squad we're gonna
name you in it
and um
yeah we're i think it was like two one
or two day camps before the team got
named and then
uh we played the blues at albany and
after the game
got called out of the sheds and there
was aaron shannon steve hansen and they
said we're gonna name your nail blacks
tomorrow so
it was crazy to think that you know it
was only three years ago i was playing
yeah first 15 footy
matt you must have sold yourself bloody
well what did you say
honestly i can't remember i remember
staying up like then like it was
homework almost like writing down stuff
and like what i am working on what i
need to get better at
i've always been like reasonably
self-aware
of my strengths and weaknesses
um
yeah hopefully it wasn't the sales but
hopefully it happened
again i think i was a little bit
fortunate with it with the timing you
know like it was 2012 it just came off
the 2011 world cup steve hanson's first
year as coach and they
were looking to bring in some some new
players some new blood
if i'm brutally honest there's probably
players who are more deserving than me
at that time um in my career but um
i was unfortunate like it was funny
enough it was a series against
um ireland 10 years ago and
there's a couple injuries in the first
game
so i was on the bench for the second
test karen reed got concussed i was on
at half time so you know pretty lucky to
get a debut of 40 minutes yeah
i don't know if you remember the one
where dc um being the droppy was not
long to go oh yeah yeah yeah so that was
my debut game and then
because rito was still dusty the next
week
richie started at eight and i got to
start at seven in just my second test
match at hamilton so
yeah crazy crazy month really yeah so
when when you're coming off the bench
for the all blacks how are you feeling
you're feeling ready you're wanting to
get out there as soon as you can
honestly i think because i was only 20
like i didn't even like take it all in
properly yeah you know it's just like
things were happening fast and whirlwind
i do like so much so i wasn't thinking
about too much that to the point that we
rocked up to the game and we walked out
onto the field to check out the ground
as you do before the game
me and brody metallic um were flatmates
and had debuted the week before yeah
walking on the field looking at the big
screen and they were showing the haka
and i thought
oh [ __ ]
i don't know if i know the hacker well
enough
so there i am going to brody saying
hey bro after we go
on that side and then two on that side
do we get is it one more and then we go
under arm and then up
and then he's going ah
i think you slapped your left arm in
your right arm and
and then i go bro we better stop this in
case um
in case there's a camera record
yeah yeah okay so we walked back inside
and sure enough one of the sky cameras
is
on the ground watching us
well he i'm trying to teach me the
hacker that he doesn't even know himself
oh
so you're not here lessons this one's
come up a few times
even said he learnt off youtube some
guys say they're learning about
themselves i don't get it
who doesn't know the hacker
we do it at captain's run
but it's real low-key
and um
and you're at the back obviously yeah
when you start out so you can sort of
like
get away with what what you know and if
you if you're really unsure you can
always go and ask the person who's
leading it but um
i think that's probably too shy or so
just
i think i know it
was wrong with it then it wasn't until i
saw the
footage on the big screen i thought ah
man i don't want to go like slap my left
down once and then go to the right arm
and everyone's still on their left so
just just wanted to clarify that a
little bit i think i know the
rest oh something obviously that's this
indication of help you know i was just
taking it in my stride yeah
and then it was kind of good it was
actually quite good that uh i don't i
don't know rito had a concussion i don't
think he really did until he got in at
half time and said he wasn't feeling
right
and again i don't wasn't sure that was
happening i was just about to go back
out on the field to warm up with the
boys and then they just said oh sam
you're on
you know it was like two minutes before
we ran out second half yeah holy smokes
okay sweet let's go
and then um i do remember i was standing
beside dc
dan carter just as he was about to kick
off for the second half
and like i knew i'd been named in the
all blacks obviously but i also knew
that you're not an all black until you
take the field
and i was like in that moment as the
whistle went and he kicked off for the
second half as i took my first couple of
steps i was like
yeah boy it's all black now
yeah yeah
first of all
um yeah just got stuck in and you've
sort of spoken we've sort of skipped
over your chiefs but a little bit but
when you went into the chiefs um you
were going into the side which was
probably the fourth the best team in the
competition at the time i think they'd
won back-to-back competitions around the
time you you joined them so that
obviously had a big impact in your
career what was what was so good about
that chief side well i actually my first
year the chiefs was before dave rennie
and in those two titles so they burned
in 2011 and then
yeah 2012. to be fair like on paper
everyone wouldn't have said oh that's
the best side it's one of those things
he'd
picked like if you got quite a few guys
that were almost a little unknown
michael versus jewel um andrew horrell
celie tickle the tumor guys um we got a
few good signings like robert robinson
had come up
aaron cruden was a massive one
um you know brady would tell it was
pretty well unknown he's a 20 year old
from play from hawke's bay and
went on to play like every game for us
that season and the rest is history but
being tamiya funa a lot of like a good
mix of young guys and i think that's
where ren's had a little bit of
an edge is that he'd been the new
zealand under coach so but so he had a
relationship with a lot of these guys
and he was able when he became head
coach he was able to bring them in
and to the chiefs um
but man we uh i don't know any different
but we train seriously hard where wrens
wayne smith tom commentary andrew
strawbridge with a great coaching team
and now
like i said just taking in your stride
just lapping it up and loving being a
professional player and i was lucky i
was getting selected in the 23 every
week and i'm not it was just awesome
yeah we were we lost our first game i
think to the holidays but then we went
on a really good run of winning about
nine games in a row
and um i was the team that had had a lot
of belief
we're well coached we're well led as
well and craig clark and liam messen it
was the first time sort of co-captains
were
thrown about in new zealand rugby and it
worked really well for us
and yeah we just
i know those those semi-finals against
the crusaders and hamilton were just
incredible um memories really with the
the crowd
how how tight the winds were i think one
was like 2019
and then the other one was like 23 20s
just
massive i mean we're lucky to just i
think home field advantage in a final we
never had to travel it was huge and
really push the boat out after after
those sort of games
and by all accounts your sessions were
all pretty hard like pretty intense
especially that thursday sessions from
from the sounds of things it was always
pretty much like a a match before the
match for you guys yeah and like i said
i didn't know any difference so it
wasn't really i wasn't really thinking
um fire atlas's heart out that was just
all i knew yeah um but then there was
other guys like liam neeson saying man i
don't know if we can do this every
single year
i'm not gonna last
um but yeah rins would build uh really
strong depth and competition within the
squads by
changing players every week i think the
only time we had the same
23 that year was for the semi in the
final other than that the team changed
every single week and that put a lot of
internal competition but then also
the message was
uh if you're not playing and you want to
get in the 20s if you want to get
playing you need to show us at training
so then there'll be guys with a bit of a
chip on their shoulder and that'd bring
the heat and then obviously
you know when you're in the team and
someone from the opposition is putting
the heat at training and not bugging
this guy so
it's just intensity just ramps up slowly
before you know it
yeah it's all go pepe that was cool are
you one to get into before in the chat
on the training field no i won't go um
looking for it but if there's
no no no not really i've no i've only
had a cup i only had a couple my whole
career and i've probably been with my
mates one was with
leah messen it wasn't serious
it wasn't too bad and
me and brodie had a little go once
pretty much on for those type of things
that you know training's supposed to be
at a certain level you know 60 or 70
percent whatever yeah someone comes in a
full wall and the other person's like
what the hell if you up to you
you know it too well so yeah
and then everyone stands around them
i'll make up after it yeah
oh that's good stuff yeah
well one big part of your career has
been your injuries you've had a huge
amount of injuries um some really
serious ones as well obviously your
fractured neck stands out as probably
the toughest one to recover from what's
what's it been like dealing with some of
these injuries in particular that one
yeah um
i probably feel like i get a little i do
get a little bit frustrated at the
how much injuries are talked about
for for me and i realized that i've had
two major surgeries off in the last
three years so that's that's justified
but
i can't do it like an interview these
days or something without someone saying
oh the injuries of this or that yeah
i've made i've actually
played live at 200 games in the last 10
years so it's about 20 20 a season i
must be on the field a reasonable amount
of time but um
still being stuck with a tag you know um
i've got to try to shake that
oh
i haven't been into this season other
than just a little um
mcl tweak which is you know i was out
for two weeks that you wouldn't really
it's just a niggle yeah
but it doesn't don't change things um
filthy with the injury tag oh
i won the other day and they just no
one's had to pick themselves up off the
ground more than you now the amount of
injuries you've had
hold up mate [ __ ] up
it's not that bad
i guess it's the big neck one really
isn't it that everybody remembers you
because that was one where people were
really doubting whether you'd be able to
return to the game or not and how you've
done it yeah very inspirational yeah i
think you're right um that one
was just a really unfortunate accident
as an accident really is timing um just
saying things that
you know and and rare i went into the
cleaner guy out
i sort of lined him up early
i thought
going hard here and just as i had um
i think it was ryan karate it cleaned
him from the other side so it just
changed the position of his hip
and i was targeting sort of his rib area
and as a result my head went straight
into into his hip bone and i just felt
like a crunch a lady i thought i was um
just a bit dazed
but concussed and knocked out and then
i just had a massive intense pins and
needles all down my right arm and but
i've had stingers before it was more it
was worse than that yeah but it did it
did go away and then i remember seeing
the other doctors were there and i
remember seeing bodhi there and um the
bring out that little golf cart thing to
put me on
and i was like no there's no way
it's not that bad i know what's happened
i'm just i'm knocked out so i asked him
to pull me up and he pulled me up and
then um we were walked off i saw you
when i was walking off man i feel pretty
ginger here
and we went out the back of the stadium
they wanted to put me on some gas i said
i'd say [ __ ] not too bad i think and
they said oh we want to take you to
hospital
man this is annoying
um but i must have so much adrenaline
and just like the in fact i've been i
was warm and on the field because by the
time i got in the ambulance and we were
on the way to the hospital man the pain
started to kick and push on
yeah yeah and um
but not at any point did you think oh
i've fractured my neck
because no one knows what that feels
like really unless you picture it
so
wanting to know how the boys were
getting on in the game yeah it was a
tight game
um
but even once we got a hospital you know
i was sitting up um i had to go in for a
x-ray it's lying down
a lot of pain
but swing myself back up and lie on the
bed hit my phone and then next minute
they doctors and nurses rush in and put
a brace around me and start running
their hands over my feet can you feel
this can you feel that far out what's
going on now and that was the moment
they they said oh you've
uh broken your neck and
your vertebrae in two places um it's a
fracture dislocation actually so
actually vertebra is like your
yeah each vertebrae is like a round
circle almost um broken it in two places
and that that piece is is dislocated
forward yeah people ask if i was if i
was scared or what but
because at no point i couldn't feel my
legs or feet or anything
and then i was already in their care
at no point did i sort of feel like i
was gonna go backwards from where i was
so i didn't really have that
massive fear of am i not going to be
able to walk or
anything like that i did just have the
the worry in the back of my head that i
wasn't going to be able to play rugby
again but in that moment it didn't seem
that important
um either
considering the injury yeah
and is it true that you were like only
your really strong neck which you do
have a massively strong neck saved you
saved you from not being able to yeah
yeah it is it is um
so the surgeon um showed me two x-rays
this was after surgery
one was mine and one was a 15 year old
south african boy and they were almost
identical and that
poor fella
he's in a wheelchair now the rest of his
life um and the difference was that i
all the sort of
built up muscle and strength around my
neck and upper back
so when my body almost went as a shock
and all those muscles just spasmed up
and stopped that that fractured that
dislocation piece um from going any
further or moving around and damaging
more spinal cords so yeah that was a bit
of a sobering moment i think and a
realisation of how lucky
i was or how close i could have been to
being just like that that 15 year old
south african boy
that's crazy that is crazy it makes you
straight away made me appreciate him and
thankful for all the the nick and
strength work that uh the trainers get
you doing yeah had you done extra you
like you you do have a
very strong big thick neck
have you done extra neck work from a
young age or is this a part of the hay
bale routine
it's like like bodhi's six-week speed
program
no honestly i think it's just one of
those
things that i'd almost genetically um
i wouldn't at all i wouldn't have said
it was a genetic gift up until um
he had an injury because i used to get
so much [ __ ] from the boys about it and
then
whenever we have outfitting
swimming on me but it just fits my neck
and i have to move the button a bit
further
and taper in the hot the rest of the
food
but yeah it turns out to be a bit of a
blessing and yeah i don't do i don't do
any more next work than anyone else
leading up to the injury um
and i'll probably only do a little bit
more now not guilty you don't need to
overdo it like your neck was strong
beforehand and that's what saved you you
don't need to then you know begun
all that just keep doing what you're
doing so i keep ticking away at it but
we did make sure it tested the other day
and it's um you know
up there with with the props neck
strength so i think it's just one of
those things no doubt i'm lucky
and then when you're coming back from a
fractured neck like how hard is this one
this is the one that like once you feel
like it's recovered how do you go about
being able to play throw your body into
contact knowing that what you've been
through
if i'm honest i think like i my shoulder
surgery last year
i found the shoulder
rehab process more difficult than one
equine oh yeah for different reasons um
mushroom surgery was a pretty it was a
major and it ended up having four
operations sort of tied into one but
just the
small rehab work and the
almost micro gains that or sometimes
feel like i wasn't making any gains yeah
by the end of the week and
chipping away at that compared to my
neck because it was a bone just needed
time to heal
but the biggest hurdle i had to overcome
was just the the mental one of getting
back and playing
yeah after
so i was
three months in the neck brace where i
couldn't
do anything i wasn't told it was time
not to lift anything more than three
kilos so this time of being so
sort of almost precious with my body and
so i've become so fragile and with
things uh just had to work my build my
way back up to
throwing myself around like i remember
the first time i got the old clearance
from the surgeon
and i can get back into rugby training
physio's live we just want you to be on
your knees and then fall to the ground
and it's like oh
and that was such a mental hurdle for
myself because
i've just been looking after it so well
yeah i was like well i'll be all right
yeah and then there's just all these
little hurdles from there of
you know once i've done that and you
know my and it's all in your mind you
know once i've done that oh i'm okay
doing that maybe i'm okay doing this but
each time it
doesn't feel any easier than the next
step or the last step yeah and right up
until the point that you're tackling it
um
i've got um tomboy matson to thank for
all the he spent hours with me working
on my he was our defense coach at the
chiefs at the time
up on the mats
doing tackle practice with him to the
point that i was really confident
and i was confident going into my first
game i was off the bench versus the
blues and um
got on earlier than i'd anticipated
because there's a couple injuries but i
got out there and i wasn't that
confident man i was like running around
i couldn't help but think about it going
into collisions
and when i watch the game you can't tell
that i'm hesitant but in my mind i was
hesitant yeah yeah and then
i thought after that man this is going
to take maybe a bit longer a bit harder
than i thought i've always had the
attitude after an injury like if you're
going to play you just got to rip in
like you just got to go hard from the
outset yeah and not
not think about it because you are but i
couldn't help but think about it it was
it was weird i never had that issue
before
um the next week i got named to start
and so i just said the same attitude
like i've just got to rip him and um
i don't know why exactly but i got over
it that second game straight away it
wasn't in my head yeah and then
every now and then i'll find myself in a
similar clean out position and it's
almost i don't know it must be like a
a line in my
memory path to my brain traumatic one of
knowing what that'll been in this
position before and it's no good yeah um
i'm also a little bit better around
south preservation um i think
i
can cast
a few times earlier in my career because
i just goes hard into things and try and
like dominate every collision or just
trying
whenever every moment i could and now
because i've had to i just
have um
tried to pick moments a little bit
better you know i don't have to smoke
everyone i remember
it's a short line out against aussie
david pocock 10 metres back i'm 10
meters back i knew he was getting the
ball i just sprinted as hard as i could
and tried to smoke him
and he's just a
little ball of muscle and i collected
his hip yeah i wasn't cast
one of my kids just sat me down look at
this collision do you really think
you're gonna
this is a good one to try and win
you just gotta make the tackle here you
don't have to send them
trying to send them backwards and i was
like
again it was a moment i'll say it makes
a lot of sense here gotta start trying
trying to play a bit smarter
mate that's fascinating fascinating
hearing the
the mind battle coming back from andrea
yeah i mean you obviously throw your
body and you have to throw your body
into contact you definitely have a
reckless regard for your body when you
watch your place so um to have that
mindset is so important for you to be
able to perform i guess yeah it's
exactly like i've sort of thought that
that's how i play that's how i play well
and it comes with that high risk but
i wasn't sure if i'd be able to sort of
make those decisions in game yeah um and
but i have i have learnt to yeah luckily
hopefully it can
actually take another
three four five years onto my career
no doubt but we i do want to talk to you
about your all black career a little bit
more any standout games from your career
where you think man that was
that was so cool um
any standout games couple of rugby world
cups you've been involved in obviously
the 2015 one was would have been pretty
special to be a part of yeah 2015 team
like look through that squad that was
just
an incredible team to be a part of um
yeah i mean and i was lucky i actually
got to play um quite a lot of minutes at
that world cup um richie had a few
niggles and um the warm-up games so i'm
starting more games and getting more
game time than i thought i would i was
realistic but
always was i was behind the skipper then
so like any game time i could get was
going to be awesome and even right from
the start of my black career i got name
in the rugby championship squad after
that all in one steve hansen pulled me
aside instead you probably won't play
any games
so it told me straight up
um
and i was like okay so that completely
changed my attitude and i thought well
i'm here in the all blacks this is a
dream result for me i've just got to try
and be a better i'm going to use it to
be a better rugby player
by the time i finished the week than
when i started training with these guys
working hard
and if i get an opportunity i just got
to try and take it
and luckily i got one game off the bench
that year
and in one game
in india too
but i actually appreciated that he told
me that rather than making my hopes up
for this week
so when the team came i was like i'm not
gonna be named and then when it finally
did holy
but it taught me also um it served me
really well for this later part of my
career when i
um do start regularly what young guys
are going through and they sometimes
forget that you've been there or they
don't realize that you've actually been
there too and you've had to go through
those training weeks where you know
you're not playing you've got to help
prepare the team put the team first but
still work hard at your own game to try
and be better yeah and even in 2000
yeah even in that 2015 world cup you're
behind
the skipper behind richie but when you
got a start against namibia you were
skipper too weren't you yes true yeah
that is that's right um
and that was just completely out of the
blue i didn't see that coming yeah we're
really short turnaround or at the world
cup where it was maybe like four days so
they pretty much changed um the teams up
and
[Applause]
yeah steve just said oh
won't you be skipping for the game i was
actually walking down the road to get a
haircut
on your day off steve was driving and he
was in a cab he put jumped out
so he told me got back in the cab and
drove off
um
it caught me off guard massively um
in onsite man i wasn't even really like
ready for it i wasn't ready for it at
all i don't think i'd even captain the
chiefs at that stage
and
as a result i didn't actually play
overly well against namibia i was too
worried about everyone else which was
just now that i think about that stupid
don't worry about
anyone else can they just worry about
yourself but um
still awesome learning experience also a
massive privilege obviously um in my
family or over at that world cup so i
got to take them out for a coffee and
tell them in person which was which was
really cool there's obviously legends
throughout that squad was it
intimidating at all to be named captain
obviously you're so young it hardly
started you like you'd mention massively
i remember um
without a clarity session
so that just come off a game and it was
us who hadn't come off again
let's see that i was going to be skipper
and just before you go away i thought
now i'm going to say something here
we've got a huddle
and um said
it was like a lot of us have helped
prepare you guys so i'm talking to the
lights of richie and dan and rito and
jimmy lammon
all these boys a lot of us we've helped
you guys prepare for these first year
games uh just ask that you guys help us
prepare the best we can to play and
almost telling them
we're trying to ask them the nicest way
yeah
and i've like rehearsed it in my brain
on the way to
right to the training numerous times on
the bus
oh
i love that stuff and then obviously um
you win that rugby world cup what's that
feeling like yeah just
just awesome um
i can't really put it into words i i
was the shortest test cap of my career
actually woke up finally i got on for 30
seconds
actually i was just about i'm pretty
sure i was just about to go on i've been
asked to warm up which is a good sign
being on the bench if you get asked to
warm up what time is this
i think it was about like 25 minutes to
go
and that's when i had been going on
previous games in the quarter in the
semi and then
bender got yellow carded oh that's right
yeah
yeah
and uh whoa i'll hold that man sit back
down sit back down
during that time i think the aussies i
haven't listened to bender's podcast i
can't remember exactly but the aussie
school day yeah when bender was off yeah
yeah and they were actually looking
quite good for a moment there so i will
leave sam on the bench and then um when
after after boater you got that right
away try
right you can go on now
i think he cleaned a rack off the
kickoff
didn't know he pretty much kicked it out
yeah oh the life on the bench
yeah life on the bench and come on
bender
who knows if he hadn't who got that card
maybe i would have got into this but
that was awesome i didn't honestly but
it didn't bother me because of the the
occasion yeah how awesome it was um
yeah struggle to find the words to
explain it just a special experience to
be part of is a is a 23 year old you
know some good mates and just some some
legends of the game yeah and then
rolling on four years 2019 rugby world
cup how did this one compare for you
um yeah i was really excited about this
one because um
since
2015 sort of established myself as the
the starting all black sealant and so
this world cup was
i really wanted to have a
i knew i was part of the squad and i
played a good part but i wanted to have
like more of an impact on on the field
and the big moments when we helped us
lift another one and um
the world cup itself like the experience
in japan
the
but it was awesome the people
so hot when we first got there i
couldn't believe how hot it was
um but but loved it all
our campaign was a little bit disrupted
i think we
in our last pool game there's the
like cyclone which one that went through
yeah it's like typhoon you know ordered
something that went through um so our
game against the league got cancelled
and then we put on a performance against
ireland in the quarterfinal that was
just like close to one of those perfect
games and to be fair in 2015 we'd done
the same against france and then in 2015
we backed up against south africa that's
right but we didn't play overly well but
we we got through it's just like the
difference in performance so we knew
that we played really well against
ireland in 2019 we needed to back it up
and that that performance probably
wouldn't look anything like
the one against ireland we just needed
to get a job done and um look that week
was one of the
probably one of the tougher weeks i've
had as an all black because
i got told on
on the monday night from steve that i
wasn't going to be starting it's going
to be on the bench after i think i've
started every test i've been available
up until that point since 2015 so
that was uh
it's tough to swallow um because of the
the magnitude of the game and
where i felt i was in my career and
it hurt
but at the same time i
respected the way he told me
he rationalized his reasons
around wanted to target their line out
so
having screwed about at six
and
he gave me a good reason about
coming off the bench at the time and i i
just had to accept it and agree
i mean again i said sort of pick myself
up that gave myself that night to be
able to suck to myself and then the next
day i was live i'm still a leader in
this team i've got to prepare the best i
can and help the team and know that i
could still have an impact come off the
bench but um
obviously that day we were just beaten
by and went inside it was it was on
another level and that they were too
good for us that day that
there still stings to be honest it sucks
we didn't get it right
[Music]
no no we had it hurt that i was on the
pine for it and uh
we just didn't have the answers that day
when they
they were coming at us yeah how long did
you get on that one longer than 30
from him right yeah i think i came on at
halftime to be honest
yeah yeah
so once you've
once you're on that bench and you're
watching that game
you're watching england
absolutely dominating us physically
what are you thinking honestly i want to
get on there out there and just
hit some people
like i
i was chomping a little bit to get out
there and
probably in hindsight i was like a
little bit even over eager i gave away a
penalty for smacking one of the fully
mini polo boys slightly off the ball i
thought he was going to get the ball i
just went through the tackle just like
almost a little bit over aroused you
know
um trying to make it a bit trying to
make a statement um
also trying to impact the game you know
like trying to lift us and
and
do something that could help change the
momentum but um
yeah
it didn't work out mate it hurts i can
feel it yeah it does it does um
yeah it does hopefully um
hopefully we can
sort it out next year
yeah and what sort of position do you
think all blacks are in heading into
obviously the 2023 world cup yeah look
like the last two years have been pretty
disruptive and unique for an
overweight's team um i mean i said 20 to
only six test matches
last year
plenty of test matches but all on the
road so yeah that i think that as a as a
squad like we're a pretty tight group
because of what what we've been through
and there's a lot of depth it'll just be
about
now
guys really staking their claim for that
starting their starting jersey and
making it their own and sort of going to
another level because if i look at that
2015 world cup squad
i will look back and it's one of the
great squads that's been assembled but
there's numerous players who are best in
the world in their position and really
dominated their spots and
with certain picks and
that's the challenge for a lot of us in
this current team is we need to
make some some strides and and take our
game as individuals to just another
level so that we can
as a team go one go all the way next
year and we'll world rugby is in a good
space at the moment there's a lot of
teams playing well it's going to be it
is going to be some world cup there's no
real clear favorite on who's going to
win this thing obviously the bookies
have france's favorite um all black
second favorite but um there's probably
a number of up to six or seven teams
that could probably win this rugby world
cup i agree but world rugby is so strong
but long gone are those days where
remember they all got to see the team on
india tour and and change their team
week to like the whole 15 almost yeah
right
man it's a world
a great spot and that
the difference in the styles that
different teams are playing as well and
the different challenges
they present we haven't seen in super
rugby you know we've gone from the kiwis
playing each other to them playing the
aussies and just the slightly different
style of rugby that they play and how
you have to adjust and how to fix your
own game so
yeah exciting times
great looking forward to it and post
world cup what's the sort of plans for
you have you got
um he contracted just up to the right
world cup any sabbaticals what's what's
the plan for sam k
i'm contractors until
2025. oh gee so
yeah so i'm only just turned 30 started
this year so i feel like
um plenty out
right neared me and
yeah i've had those
little hiccups the last couple years but
almost they might yeah there's one of
the physio said mate that might and it
might tap you on another year at the
backing yeah just having a little warren
fitness little breather mid career so
um
yeah contract 2025 i do have the option
um post world cup of doing one of those
little
japan stints like some of the boys have
done um
so
we'll look into that it's um
it's been sort of a long time doing
similar
routines and similar stuff here in new
zealand but at the same time
i'm really grateful and love what i'm
doing and
[Music]
love being around friends and family but
everyone who's been
to japan not even talking to bodhi
betty barrett and
guzzler burrito talent you know just the
the little refresh even for six months
of doing something completely different
in a different environment where
it can be refreshing so we'll see
there's no guarantees that you can even
pick one up you know it's not like
they're just handing them out but
they'll be coming crawling for you with
huge amounts of room no doubt all black
skipper oh high priority oh yeah and and
that would be nice to
everyone that go just for the just for
the experience hey yeah
and post buddy what's the plans for you
deer farm um not 100 sure uh i would
like
really um like to have a bit of land
maybe not not massive but maybe 100
acres or something partly because i love
my childhood on the farm so much too and
my wife she's off a dairy farm she she's
the same we thought it'd be quite cool
for our kids to
experience some of those same things uh
we're not not set on that though but
we've got a big idea at the moment we'd
like to own some land
but also still be involved in rugby in
some capacity not on like
not super rugby coaching or anything
like that because i want a change of
schedule change of structure but uh
maybe maybe more like
under 20s or under 19s or age group
stuff yeah
we can just sort of pass on a bit of
knowledge and
find out i always find it quite exciting
like seeing more hearing about who
young guys are coming through
[Music]
and how they develop so yeah maybe an
ideal world would be a bit of both a
little rugby and maybe a bit of farming
or something else yeah how good is that
oh well exciting times ahead but um as
always we've gone to our instagram for
some questions and all black skipper has
come in with
thousands and thousands of questions
i've had to filter them out um obviously
a lot were around how you deal with the
pressure around publicity and all that
sort of things but we did have quite a
few good ones come through first one was
um how hard was it early in your career
being labeled the next richie mccoy how
hard was that i don't know if i really
like
took it on me that to be the next
frictional core i think as it was always
put to me particularly by steve hanson
like whenever i played just go out and
play as sam kane be yourself um but i
consider myself so fortunate to have
those pretty much four full seasons with
richie like playing and training with
him in the all blacks environment but
for me
today bert 20 he'd already been in the
all blacks for 10 years by that stage so
like i was a 10 year old when i started
sort of
watching him and
and idolizing his play so just
what
well
a
consider myself really lucky to have
learnt off him but at no point that i
ever um
sort of try and be the next rich in the
corps
and look to be fair i don't know if
there will ever will be another
richard mccoy after what we've seen what
he's achieved um but yeah
didn't
really take it on myself to be him yeah
you see these labels being chucked out
all the time as soon as
young kids come through they're labeled
the next someone so how many jonah how
many next one
any big fast winger was a gym in the
next jonah
yeah you're right that's good that it
didn't affect you but the next one which
chief's front rower can sink the most
waikato drafts
and i know it won't be old oven mitts
and gustavo
he would rate himself all right
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know player rates
in south so highly um
yeah he could put them away
yeah
he could bend with he can bend with the
best of the way i remember
after
after one of the those
titles we won he turned up to the parade
on monday and he was still wearing his
number ones from saturday
but man yeah he's a good man and he can
put them away
that's good stuff okay next one oh from
our sponsor swish i know you're on swish
too you're one of the great guys on
swish um so if you are listening and you
want to swish from the all black captain
sandca and get amongst that but if sam
kane could get a video shout out from
any celebrity who would it be and why
wow that's a great question
oh probably the first one that came to
my head was uh roger
federer yeah just um
not that i'm great at tennis but i've
just always admired him and the way he
goes about his work like my old man was
a big fan of and he loves his tennis
roger federer growing up so like
we'd often watch and watch him um
yeah that'd be cool he's he is a legend
he would he'd get on the podcast i
reckon but do you get many does it
what do you reckon
you've got contacts with everyone i'll
send them i'll send them out my
instagram message straight
straight to message requests
um do i get many switch requests um
i don't know
one every couple of weeks maybe oh geez
like that they'll be flying after us
okay next one who is the toughest
opponent oh this is going to be tough ah
i always find these questions quite
tough
their toughest opponent because it's
such like a team sport you know you're
always facing the team and depending on
how the teams go that day i do remember
my first start for the chiefs i vividly
remember
standing in the back line off a short
line out we were on defense and looking
across and brad thorne was standing
directly opposite me yeah about to carry
the ball and i was
[ __ ] this guy is huge
this looks so hard like everything on
them
it was like like one of the moments in
game we were like man i'm just a boy out
here with me yeah
um
[Laughter]
when he came back to super rugby got the
opportunity to play against him a couple
of times so that was that was pretty
cool and
yeah found him a pretty tough competitor
he was a legend too
okay next one what is your mindset
before going into contact is it absolute
fury or is it more technique
um okay in a moment before going into
contact i think
you don't really like
have a mindset as much
um it's just about like sort of trusting
all the work you've done against things
you're just reactive you know it's
such a reactive sport just
going off instincts more work goes in
early but i think
you can go into games with your mindset
and note your intent
in the right spot compared to other
games
and that's the the mental battle and the
mental challenge of getting yourself an
estate to go with the right intent um to
to
you know do some damage or dominate
collisions um but then at the same time
like your technique has to be right
because particularly these days we see
how
our red cards can impact games in the
international season the red cards won't
be 20 minutes
because world really couldn't agree on
the northern hemisphere couldn't agree
on the red card for the 20 minutes or
the full
rest of the game off so um the
consequences are huge it's important
about having good intent
particularly for ford's you know our
game's dominating collisions in the
majority of it so you've got to go in
with
intent and aggression but um there's not
much room for error with the technique
how do you make sure your mindset's
always right for that um
like
you slowly sort of work yourself up
throughout the week a little bit and
then i think as i i just took the game
so seriously that would be like
all-consuming about leading up like game
day would be terrible company and
couldn't have laughed and so strict on i
think stuff like for a lot of guys they
basically get older you
um realize um it's about the work that
goes in during the week not about sort
of
whether you have a coffee at 10 a.m or
11 a.m
so
uh
i don't know
it runs everyone's different you know
like you'll see guys in the students who
can have a a laugh before kickoff
and the warm-up and then go out there
and turn it on other guys have to be
really serious that's about what works
for you and i'm probably sort of halfway
house you feel like i can switch off a
little bit but i
also sort of have a bit of an attention
that slowly builds yeah
oh i like it okay next one this might be
a little bit similar to toughest but
hardest player to tackle who do you
least want to be one-on-one with
no one
[Music]
hardest guys i reckon
uh like the the short stocky powerful
guys but like you they have footwork as
well you know like a
you know like a narnia market because he
cannot run over you but he could also
beat you with footwork or um
guys guys like that um
struggling to think of another one moves
like that um
i used to do
back in the day
when sevens used to go off the tail of
the line out
i'd often over chase the winger or the
or the first five and that's step back
against me yeah so i was like right i've
got to get better at this sold work on
it with um who i think's like got the
best footwork a silly ticket yeah
and so i'll come from an angle and he
can
on me once i get to the stage that i can
attack and let me know about attacking
anyone
and it just
he different circles around me time and
time
he would he would if he'd stop i think
he's gonna step back then he'd goosey
and take off again i'll be left there or
if i thought he was gonna juicy just
whack me back on the inside and got to
the point after like three trainings of
doing this
i was like my confidence is shot i've
gotta
get one of the props of me
[Laughter]
so oh that that that three week period
of trying to get better at that
[Music]
okay next one can you please get sam's
thoughts on dalton oh dalton's uh
he's outstanding yeah um we roomed
together a couple years ago i've just
always my adults as a person so like
he's such a good man he'd be one of the
first bikes to currency after the game
be like now i thought you played really
well or like awesome game um
and then whenever we've played each
other he's just such a tough competitor
you know
he's a big physical man
and
it's been been awesome to see him right
step into the strip roll with the blues
and do so well um he ran out like up the
loose fords within the all blacks last
year like the little
loose fords units and um really really
enjoyed him running that day his sense
of humor and
but also his intensity so
um
yeah look like i've got no doubt i don't
take my position in the team for for
granted and just because i've been named
skipper for this three match series
doesn't guarantee
um anything so i know that he's he's
putting his hand up big time to be
starting for the all blacks and we
obviously play the same position um so
yeah i've just got to worry about my my
game can't sort of look back and see
who's chasing and just make sure i play
as well as i can
he's more of a six though right
[Laughter]
okay last question best piece of advice
for a water led listener oh all black
skippers don't come on often so i'm
looking forward to this one
worst part is when you roll listen to
the water lead potties i listen to their
advice and i think from everyone i want
me to have some great wisdom
i've always
like thought it's important to be
for lack of a word a better word
coachable so you know someone and it
doesn't just apply to to rugby but
someone you like you want to be a person
or admire people who are always open to
receiving feedback and want to get
better and
totally the other way you see people who
or you
come across people who you may suggest
feedback to or you see them get it and
they almost take it personally or as
criticism
yeah but i've learned that almost the
further up you go the rugby ranks too
and the better the rugby players are the
more open and the more they're seeking
feedback um
and it's not just with rugby no matter
what it is and they're always trying to
be better at everything they do better
people
better partners better fathers like that
just want to be
better than they are and to do that it
involves often seeking feedback and
taking advice on board whether you agree
with it or not that's up to you
but just be someone who
i think it's important to be someone who
takes advice um takes feedback on board
and and tries to be better every day
oh mate one of the great i knew it i
knew the all black skit would deliver
there was a bit of pressure on that
device but
my word did you deliver that was
definitely planned
yeah yeah yeah
no i always say that one
oh i know but mate it's been an absolute
pleasure having you on the podcast been
awesome going through your journey
hearing how you've uh got to the top to
where you are now and mate what i'm
really excited for is um these next few
years seeing you
injury-free i know you always have been
just a couple injuries
it's been blown out there's been waves
going out but
that's it
start that narrative and then taking the
all blacks to the rugby world cup and
hopefully lifting that trophy over there
in france it's going to be um an awesome
journey and i really appreciate you
coming on the podcast i appreciate it
jimmy i've really enjoyed being on and
like i said i've been a long time
listener and enjoyed listening to the
arms with some of the boys
over the last couple years so
good work mate thanks for catching up
mate you're one of the greats appreciate
it cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]